eingang tägliche routine green und
tochter sophia brauchen was für kopf und
magen beides gibt es im rathaus seit
monaten ist die alleinerziehende er ihn
auf die tafel im londoner stadtviertel
vollem angewiesen ihren job als
reinigungskraft hat sie verloren corona
und tochter sophia verliert den
anschluss in der schule weil sich die
familie kein breitbandinternet leisten
kann
ganz ehrlich es ist so schwierig jedes
mal wenn ich mich versuchen eine der
lernplattform einzuloggen stürzt die
webseite komplett ab oder es dauert so
lange oder die lehrer fragen mich wenn
ich es endlich in die online klasse
geschafft habe warum ich wieder und
wieder so spät also befüllt sie am handy
über das wlan im daetz haus kurz nach
den weihnachtsferien blieben die schulen
in england zum zweiten mal zu mit jedem
tag dieses lockdown es gehe ihr ein
kleines stück zukunft verloren
ich könnte das abitur nicht schaffen es
könnte meine zukunft zerstören wenn ich
bald nach arbeitssuche und dort gefragt
werde wie meine noten so sind dann muss
ich antworten dass ich es versaut habe
sie schlecht sind
weil ich kein anständiges internet hatte
das nicht in meinen händen lag das ist
doch völlig lächerlich
kein einzelfall erklärt william mit
graham vor zwölf jahren gründete er das
daetz haus gedacht um alleinerziehende
väter zu unterstützen ist es nun stütze
für hunderte familien
es wird schlimmer als im ersten locker
und vergangenem märz der hitze gelockter
und fängt gerade erst an
keiner weiß wann die schulen wieder
aufmachen wann die menschen wieder
arbeit finden können um die familie zu
ernähren miete strom und gas bezahlen zu
können
das wird absolut katastrophal für die
nächsten fünf jahre
corona treffe alle gleich so hieß es mal
nur ein paar kilometer weiter bei den
collins zeigt sich die realität tilly
und jamie gehen auf eine privatschule
kämpfen im und mit dem schnee und damit
erzählen sie dass ihnen die freunde
fehlen aber was das homeschooling angeht
leben sie auf einem anderen stern
es läuft hervorragend der unterricht
ging online nahtlos weiter auch die
zusatzangebote etwa der musik oder der
debattierklub aller unterrichtsstunden
laufen ab genauso als ob sie in der
schule werden
ein paar selbst gedrehte bilder von
nadja collins eröffnen den blick in den
lockdown schulalltag der familie nicht
schwer zu erkennen die sehr geld corona
und schulleistungen zusammenhängen die
bildungs schere im britischen
schulsystem ging schon vor der pandemie
weit auseinander
und jeder lockdown tag sorgt für ein
wenig mehr ungleichheit bei bis zu 1,8
millionen schülern und schülerinnen
fehlt die chance auf chancengleichheit
das war seit dem ersten lockdown im
vergangenen frühjahr klar 1,3 millionen
laptops hat die regierung versprochen
lange passierte wenig mittlerweile sind
800.000 ausgeliefert was nicht reicht
und so blühen überall im land privat
initiativen auf berlin oder gespendete
geräte für eltern wie edwin aogo die
sich um die zukunft ihrer kinder sorgen
das größte geschenk nie mehr
homeschooling mit vier kindern und einem
handy
die größte sorge im land der leeren
klassenräume wie lange bleiben die
schulen geschlossen
ratlosigkeit bei den regierenden die
schulen sind ganz klar unsere priorität
aber niemand kann erwarten dass wir die
beschränkungen schnell aufheben während
die neue infektionszahlen noch immer
sehr hoch sind
das würde zu einem erneuten schweren
ausbruch führen späte einsicht des
verantwortlichen eine neue vorsicht eine
lehre aus der großen not nie gesehene
neue infektionszahlen mehr als doppelt
so viele corona patienten in den
krankenhäusern wie in der ersten welle
sowie im bräu london sie haben die zahl
der intensivbetten verdreifacht und doch
sind alle belegt ein junger mann schwere
komplikationen erklärt oberärztin
marielle aus einer familie legen mehrere
auf station zeit seine frau zu
informieren
er ist sehr krank er könnte daran
sterben es tut mir sehr leid
archiv 28 jahre ist eine chance zu
überleben 50 zu 50
es trifft diesmal viel häufiger ganze
familie seine frau janin wartet auf den
nächsten anruf ungewissheit die sie
zerreißt ebenfalls am telefon hat sie
erfahren müssen
ihr schwager im dezember der
schwiegervater vor wenigen tagen beide
gestorben an corona ohne meinen mann an
der seite fühlt sich alles zu leer an
das leben ist zu kurz und du willst es
mit denen die du liebst verbringen ich
muss stark sein für meine
schwiegermutter eine schwägerin die
brauchen mich und wenn ich
zusammenbreche weiß ich nicht wie es
weitergehen soll so etwas wie den januar
hat noch keiner im rollenden erlebt
selbst die erfahrensten droht zu
zerbrechen
es ist sehr schwierig denn diese
bedauernswerte familie hat so viel
durchmachen müssen
und sie sind wirklich so nett das macht
es noch schwieriger die wucht der januar
welle wohl eine konsequenz aus der
deutlich ansteckenden corona variante b
11 7 den lockerungen im dezember und dem
immer laxeren umgang mit hygiene und
abstand regeln
eine krise die für die jüngeren
bedeutete die schulen bleiben erst mal
zu für das daetz haus sind die
konsequenzen ebenfalls klar weiter
volles haus mit schülern die hilfe
brauchen
denn mit leerem bauch lernt es sich
schlecht ohne internet noch schlechter
dass das haus eine kleine geschichte von
trüben aussichten für einen großen teil
der generation co